sway broke up what happened there
as long as people are continuing to post
and talk about it i i think that sways a
lot
there's no better story than the sway
story i think you and nessa
got back together i mean i i don't know
where people find this information
people are gonna be confused
that's just okay that's just how it is
you mentioned
bryce and i'm just gonna ask is he okay
like what's going on with him in addison
were you
surprised by the allegations i mean i'm
not really surprised when i hear any
allegations now
i want to say congrats on crosscheck
studios
hey thank you thank you very much it's
incredible you
and mark wahlberg basically have formed
this new production company
that will focus on gen z content correct
yeah we're going to be really focusing
on the unscripted side of content but
definitely going to be that hub for
anyone in in gen z wanting to
create uh that that type of content what
were those
initial conversations with mark
like first a kid that grows up idolizing
mark wahlberg and watching his
films and seeing him be able to pivot
his career from the calvin klein model
to
marky mark and the funky bunch to now
doing movies
and and then opening up wahlburgers i i
really
respect the fact that he's a titan he's
able to
to really pivot his career that's
something i've done
throughout my uh social media careers
continuously pivot so i just really
respect that and
to be able to work together with him is
definitely a an honor
it's so funny that you were such a fan
of his
was he a fan of yours did he know who
you were did his daughters
know who you were i haven't got to ask
about his daughters no my tick tock or
anything like that i'm shooting i'm sure
they're busy watching all their dad's
movies right but when we we got to
talking
we'll all hang out i'm sure i'll film
some tech talks with his his daughters
and do some stuff there so let's talk
about this content you said it's going
to be
kate like unscripted mostly yeah
definitely
focusing on the docu-series going into
the unscripted content but
have the ability to do the scripted
content as well we definitely have a lot
of stuff on the site right now
we have some really cool stuff in the in
the sports world that we're talking
about
i mean for me someone that you know grew
up an athlete uh grew up playing sports
it's definitely cool that
that could possibly be one of the first
green lit uh things but
in i would say the next three months
we'll definitely have
a better idea of release times and
release dates is there an athlete's
whose story you would love to tell
through a docu-series
i think that derrick rose would be a
very cool story to tell just with the
the battling of
injuries and being like projected to be
one of like the best players and then
obviously having to continuously come
back from that i think that
probably what we all haven't seen from
you know the mental side of what that
does to a pro
athlete when they're not able to play
the sport they love right or the sport
there also paid millions of dollars to
do and
maybe have family uh relying on them i
would watch that one i was
obviously heartbroken by what happened
yeah
yeah his injury what about from the the
tick tock
world anyone whose story you would love
i mean there's no better story than than
this the sway story i think i don't
really think you can top it when you're
talking
like maybe the best docuseries of all
time i i would say maybe that has to be
that for tick tock it would have to be
this way is that in the works
it's always been something we've talked
about i think that like the sway boys
have always lived their lives thinking
like we're gonna have a movie be made
about us one day and
that might be like half of us being
egotistical
douches a little bit but the other half
is us like you know we're content
creators we know what
good content is so i think that there is
some truth to it hopefully and
uh it'll be some some cool docu-series
or a biographical film or something
do you feel like you guys are the
equivalent of did you ever watch
entourage
yeah of course do you guys feel like you
are entourage
i think that we have our own honorables
right we have our own little group
so i think either like a show would be
really cool or
even uh something following like the
dirt motley cruise
uh film on netflix that was wicked doing
the movie
about i think a couple of sway stories
definitely could get interesting really
get into like the real truce behind sway
would you put it all out there are there
things that you would be like i think
you have to
no i think you have to when it comes to
like the movie because then at that
point you can be like oh it's just
hollywood right
if it's like something really serious
and it's like we can't say we can just
be like that was just hollywood spicing
it up that
that didn't actually happen you know
what i mean so we have like we have that
uh leeway we have the
sway broke up what happened there
i think that people you know they're
just
throwing what they hear on the internet
together they're just throwing those
pieces
it's always a brother it's always a
lifestyle so at the end of the day
as long as people are continuing to post
and talk about it i i think that sways a
lot so
sway are you saying that sway did not
officially break up
i'm saying that i think people are
turning
the sway break up or whatever you like
people are trying to phrase it as into
something that just
isn't it's not as as much of a negative
thing as people are turning it into i
think that's where i'm trying to go with
it i think that's super helpful
is it because everyone kind of i think
moved into the triller
compound or i guess walk me through then
what happened
yeah no there's just there's been a
couple moves so though you know the boys
are uh a rowdy bunch we get up to some
stuff so it's just been like a group was
in one house and then
three people had to move to a different
one or maybe people were tired of
the noise people are all heading in
different directions as you can tell
like
with this production company with me and
mark and then you see jaden
and killing it on the music side and you
see bryson now
with really focusing in on the youtube
and entertainment everyone's
following their path and that's what
sway was for and i think that's what
people are missing out is
sway was that family that all worked
together so that we could follow our
dreams and achieve those
and that's what we talked about in all
those first meetings was like sway's
gonna be on top we're gonna crush it and
and now we're actually doing that
and i think people are like oh because
they're not doing it necessarily
all together at like the same the exact
same thing it's a breakup but it's just
everyone has their own passions right
we're not all the same person wait was
kind of the place for you guys all to
launch
now you guys have all launched is kind
of what yeah and it's like we're still
all buddies right i've hung out with
bryce a bunch of times and
i was with jayden and anthony yesterday
i opened up sports cards and
it's like we're always doing some blake
came by and showed us his collection so
it's like we're always hanging out
you mentioned bryce and i'm just gonna
ask
is he okay like what's going on with him
and addison i know you talked about this
on your podcast a little bit which is
why i'm asking you
for me it's like i'm the wrong guy to
ask right i'm not
in their relationship sadly you know i
it's
it's just bryce and addison so that's
all for him to speak about and that's
for addison's we got i don't really want
to
i don't want to put words into their
into their relationship or
or anything that they don't want to put
out on the internet you know were you
surprised by the
allegations i mean i'm not really
surprised when i hear any allegations
now on
the internet just because like people
are crazy
so they'll throw at the most offside or
the you know the most unbelievable or
detrimental to your career whatever they
there's always going to be people doing
that so i tend not to
really believe what i first hear
especially when it comes from uh
someone i have no idea or a random
source but he's doing okay right
yeah no i think i think that mentally
guys guys doing all right
in happier news you and nessa got back
together
i mean i i don't know where people find
this information right i found it on
your podcast
like you guys are now officially a
couple so we don't have to play that
fake game you're very
overt about it on social media dave
you're hitting on my girl like what's
what's going on
no no no no see that's just that's just
dave
that's just dave being dave dave was
calling her was calling her your girl
and you weren't well it's like for the
flow of the podcast what i have come to
terms with
is that it's almost just easier to like
move on right it's like
if i'm just that guy that's like no dave
no that's not what it
like every time he brings it up the
podcast ain't going
not gonna get any other content besides
me saying hey dave
we're friends and then dave being like
no you're not
so at the end of the day i was like for
for
for the fans for the people i'll just
i'll take the hit and just like roll
with it
just because i'm a great guy really well
so are you guys not back together then
i'm so confused
yeah people are people are gonna be
confused okay that's just how it is
are you guys working through things or
you're just no we're just like best
friends
oh you're just best friends i don't
think that's weird or that's confusing i
think that's like a super cool thing
you guys had to relax and now you're
best friends and your co-host refuses to
accept that
yeah co-hosts just being their their
co-host self you know do you think you
guys will get back together
i have no idea i mean like i think if
we're meant to be we will be
okay why why then this is my
last question about this but
i love our interviews they're so amazing
aren't they fun though like does it feel
like an interview or does it do no it
never really does it feels like i'm
doing like a facetime or something it's
great
i love it it's awesome she was getting
hit on by someone
i think on tick-tock an athlete's
brother
and you would have swooped in there
why because i mean i'm i'm just that
like
friend that's gonna be there to you know
how every like
everyone has the friend that has like i
gotta be careful with my wording here
i'm trying not to say anything wrong but
essentially it was just like funny i
just i i just like trolling people i
just like
people a little bit every once in a
while and like i was bored you know
bills were playing at the start of all
that drama and like
it was like super bowl season and i was
like you know what i
this guy is probably like the least
self-aware guy i could i could
find on the internet this would be
hilarious and probably some entertaining
you know pass some time covered nothing
really to do so
maybe maybe just like have some twitter
beef i love the honesty
yeah thought i gotta stay gotta stay
authentic yeah
do you feel like you're a mini mark
wahlberg in a way
that's the goal 100 right is to to be
that mogul i don't know if i can take
the
mini mark wahlberg uh title yet but
maybe after the production company
brings home an emmy then we'll we'll see
if that title can stay
what is going on on the acting front
do you have anything lined up will you
produce a movie through
crosscheck studios that you will star in
yeah of course i think that's
definitely a part of this production
company is to
hopefully have myself maybe be a star in
one of the
films but i definitely want to have the
experience of being an executive
producer too i want to be able to you
know really hone in on that
that creation of content that's always
just been something that i'm so
passionate about so we're not going to
hear an announcement tomorrow though
that's like josh richards
starring in xyz movie
i don't think you'll hear tomorrow but
hopefully you'll hear it here soon